[Music]
hello there April is yet another month
filled with amazing video games vying
for your time and money I'm here to run
you through the best of the month from
the AAA to the totally free to play
today's video is sponsored by nacon as
the console release of Transport fever 2
is here we'll be looking at that a
little later in the video so let's crack
on
Star Wars Jedi Survivor is the Marquee
game of the month once again we fill the
boots of calcustis and continue his
journey escaping Order 66 before finally
embracing his roots and becoming a Jedi
Jedi Survivor is Canon to the Star Wars
lore and is set about 10 years after
episode 3 gameplay Wise It's a single
player action adventure with low level
soulsborne inspired combat yet without
the crippling difficulty another Soul's
mechanic lets us visit meditation points
which replenish our health but also
bring back every defeated enemy in the
area exploration is encouraged as useful
items can be found away from the beaten
path Jedi Survivor adds new mechanics
like this heavy lightsaber with cross
guard inspired by kylo Ren this ties
into new fighting stances which give Cal
flexibility in engagements choosing
between faster light attacks may be
heavier attack stances to do more damage
or choosing a stance which is all about
Mobility there's an approach designed
for every battle I plan to make a video
retelling the story of Jedi Fallen order
if you've forgotten that one before Star
Wars Jedi Survivor drops on April 28th
on PS5 Xbox series and PC
[Music]
back in 2014 Dead Island 2 was revealed
and yet after it was handed from
developer to developer for almost a
decade now it is finally here and is
ready to be released this month the
first person B-movie Style zombie
dismemberment game Dead Island 2 takes
us to the sun-drenched LA are called in
game hell a ultimately Dead Island 2 is
find how many dumb and satisfying ways
you can take out zombies and that's just
fine by me there is a story here as we
are bitten by a zombie but we have not
become one of the rambling Undead so
we're immune which means we need to find
scientists in this world to manufacture
an antivirus we must play as a person
who didn't watch or play The Last of Us
along the way the world is filled with
side quests such as meeting new
characters helping them and sometimes
defeating them too I've had to cut a lot
of this footage down as YouTube is not a
fan of the gore in Dead Island 2. so
keep that in mind things get way more
gruesome than you're seeing right now if
pummeling zombies for 20 hours is your
jam it's certainly mine look out for
Dead Island 2 on PS4 and 5 the Xboxes
and PC on April 21st
a DLC you may not be aware of this month
is for Horizon forbidden West and the
burning Shores DLC the Primal and
post-apocalyptic Arrow firing mechanical
dinosaur shooting game as I'm recording
this still has no footage whatsoever of
what we'll be doing in the DLC chances
are it'll release just after I upload
this video what we know right now is
that the burning Shaw's DLC picks up the
story after the main campaign ends and I
do not plan to spoil that just know we
are going to Hollywood known as the 10x
Clan land with new characters new
machines and it's retailed at around 20
which is 16 quid here in the UK burning
Shaws is a PS5 exclusive dropping on
April 19th
have a look see at transport fever 2.
the iconic PC game has made its
long-awaited Journey over to console
alongside a complete overhaul for the
PlayStation and Xbox if you're new to
transport fever let me break it down
this is not about building a city or
following around Sim characters this is
focused on the transportation
infrastructure we are responsible for
building the tracks for trains the roads
for trucks as well as running the air
and seas for Transit by ships and planes
all with the goal of staying profitable
and business savvy transport fever 2
teaches the knowledge needed through a
campaign spanning three continents it's
also like a history lesson starting in
the 1850s in the USA and the Gold Rush
era and your job is to haul your
potential Millions away on track lines
another mission over 100 years later in
the timeline Caesars take to the shores
of Majorca to build a holidaying Empire
all thanks to air travel if you do play
this make sure you zoom into the map to
see your customers interacting with the
services you provide it's amazingly
detailed and real to life it's even
possible to spot rust on Aging Vehicles
so be sure to factoring maintenance
costs and maybe it's time to buy a newer
model of your favorite Train Transport
fever 2 is available right now on
PlayStation 4 and 5 and the Xboxes and
so the PC players don't feel left out
there's a free update there too
[Music]
okay let's do some free stuff now four
games for you but two have got caveats
first up coming in April is the console
release of warlander I mentioned this
back in January a fantasy medieval
themed free-to-play Siege Warfare MOBA
the card game mode can be played between
two armies attempting to make it all the
way into the other team's Castle to
destroy their core but to get there we
must survive brutal melee and ranged
battles between Mages clerics and
warriors claiming spawn point closer to
the opposition base and using Siege
engines and ladders to break through
enemy Gates and if Argos to plan you'll
be victorious there is also a five Army
version of this making gameplay a
constant push and pull between defending
your core and attacking as teams are
slowly Wicked down the PC version
released in January and many changes are
being made thanks to feedback which will
be applied when the console version of
Wallander drops sometime in April
another free to play game I was really
excited to tell you about is Disney
speedstorm a Disney themed racer in the
style of Mario Kart it could be amazing
I saw the release date I got excited but
then I read the fine print although
Disney speedstorm is a free-to-play game
the game is not free to play Let Me
Explain the decision has been made to
offer a paid Early Access version
instead don't get me wrong on the full
release the game will be free to play
but just like Disney Dream like Valley
they found a way to charge for a
free-to-play game hmm Disney speed storm
releases in beta form on April 18th on
Playstation Xbox PC and twitch and I'll
keep you updated on the real release
date
[Music]
thank you so let me push another
free-to-play game on your radar this
month instead honkai star rail the
follow-up game from the creators of
genshin impact using the core mechanics
they learned there to expand into other
universes like interplanetary travel and
science fiction Tech while maintaining
High fantasy elements on April 26th
honkai star rail releases on mobile and
PC with the PlayStation version
advertised by Sony as coming soon I'm
clueless how long that could be it could
be a week it could be three months like
usual I'll keep you updated okay let's
transition out of free to play and onto
lower priced games and in fact this one
is on PS Plus in April this is meet your
maker it's like a tower defense Builder
crossed with a first person raiding game
it's very unique we are tasked with
defending our fortress's core by
building around it and then it's up to
every other player in the world to try
and survive it the possibilities are
endless it's essentially Ninja Warrior
we could build hidden trap may be amazed
to get lost in or simply summon so many
hordes you overwhelm your foes or my
preference a death run that requires
skill build your own home base and then
tackle everyone else's because no two
people build the same meteor maker is
free on PS Plus in April and also drops
on Xbox and PC on April 4th
A reduced price game you might want to
look at is Minecraft Legends taking
Minecraft into action strategy honestly
it only looks like Minecraft because
almost all other mechanics are gone for
example we have a little Ally companion
who will do our bidding like cutting
down trees and collecting resources for
us we have a banner of courage to
recruit mobs to our cause but the real
focus of Legends is battling by creating
mob spawners we build our own Army and
take on other players online or
environmental opponents offline we
essentially command units from afar and
manage the fight rather than being at
the front and center Minecraft Legends
supports 8 players online simultaneously
and look there's a freaking tiger you
can ride Minecraft is changing Legends
releases on Playstation Xbox PC and
twitch on April 18th before we go a
quick mention for creed VR a face
punching simulator that arrives on psbr
2 on April 4th and check out this a
rhythm game named gods of rock a really
simple premise but instead of watching a
guy Rock On Stage hitting perfectly time
button presses it's a punch or kick to
your opponent instead April 18th if
that's your jam if you're still here
please take this Dad joke did you know
that Swimming with Sharks is expensive
it really is it cost me an arm and a leg
you're awesome I'll stop doing that one
day see ya